hey guys Mary here on gamespot.com
showing games done quick where we're
having a bunch of speedrunners run games
fast for your viewing pleasure and I'm
happy to be a long side fellow game
spotter and resident Castlevania fan
Peter Brown what up
as long as speedrunners we have to here
we have romscout ears here here to enjoy
the ride and instudio as well and your
your just hanging out as well but
actually so romscout you're gonna be
running symphony of the night in 20
minutes that's the plan right if I'm
really bad it will take 20 minutes yeah
all right golden time here uh well I
mean Oh being at under 18 would be nice
our new record I have right now is 16
minutes and 59 seconds but I don't think
I'll be doing any strategies that can
get me to that point let's not assume
anything negative everything's going
really well so little setup we'll get
right into the game right now we'll
start the timer when you say go give us
a little bit of a countdown if you can
sure um what's your name mmm I don't
know what is it Peter loves when they
make you say what your name is phrase
see the axe Armour run when you do an
axe our file like this is it for you
show you a cute chirp oh geez I got
asked why the 360 version of this game
just because it works better with the
money faster Oh a PlayStation version
gotcha yeah I will actually do a trick
with an axe arm just for you I never do
this in any right yes we're breaking new
ground this can be a new category all
right so three two one go yeah so the
intro is kind of important because any
oops
the amount of time you take to beat
Dracula actually determines your stats
and what do you get hit by them or not
also affects your steps
you need to beat them in under a minute
without getting hit for max stats
basically and then how many hearts I'm
grabbing actually matters too because if
I get over 40 hearts I get to keep an
item called the neutron bomb which is
going to let me do a skip and then if I
finish with zero hearts I get the heart
refresh which is used for additional
glitches so in total like all the stuff
put together ends up putting me with
both of those items so pretty important
it's also a cool photo like I'll say
paper best photo finish you can have
this is on New Game+ you can skip all
the cutscenes too right yeah so anytime
you speed on this game you pretty much
need to have a fuller file any tiny beat
the game have a save it indicates that
you have that so you can skip cutscenes
on your paper okay so this is you have
both hands on the run huh I wish we
could see this um so what I'm doing
right now is this thing called shield
dashing I'm trying to get a zombie spawn
also okay um this thing called shield
dashing so normally if you just back -
it's kind of fast but as a slowdown at
the end so if you kind of like mash both
the shield and the dash button
alternating then you just cancel out
that slowdown it just accept me you know
go faster slower um me and Erik Kay were
looking up other ways to hold
controllers the claw maneuver where you
kind of have the top to your fingers on
the buttons as opposed to your thumb
that way you can use the right joystick
while you're using the buttons at the
same time it's good for like fighting
games but this is like another level
where you have both hands on the buttons
at the same time um so it kind of a big
skip right there
death normally still without your
equipment and your left like with
nothing but what I actually did was I
the neutron bomb let me get a level up
from the puppy that was like slightly
off spring and time in the level up at
the point where you start to go into a
screen scroll like the pixel or screen
stroll starts horizontal and it kind of
messes up the loading for the position
of the next room and it doesn't really
put you in the right spot it just
basically skips the room it puts me on
the right side of the next door instead
of the left so I just skipped a cutscene
that way and keep all the stuff oh I
think I've run I saw you do online
earlier today you did it without any
weapons in the start you were just
punching Oh Monty yeah
I mean didn't play though I mean it was
either an old run you saw or I was doing
a glitchless category because there's a
category Oh several categories in this
game just like Bastion you sour cherries
talking about all categories you can do
right on glitch runs have a whole
different time ending right
but even without glitches this game can
be beaten in under 35 minutes so it's
not terribly long if you know what
you're doing and can shield - well yeah
I know like there's some crazy
categories for sewing like maxing out
your map percentage right which does it
goes past the normal 200 when you start
in Croatia say 203 about what I've hired
percent map or something Oh what really
yeah it's nuts because it actually
counts like out-of-bounds map ok
percentage I like when you use that fat
trick the wolf tip I don't do some I'll
bounce tricks later know why you do
stuff Peter what's your current run time
are you kidding me hours I'm a slow
runner take a average playthrough of the
game my first playthrough is somewhere
between 8 and 10 hours I've definitely
seen people take longer than that it's a
very atmosphere game and you're just
encouraged to explore quite a bit so
yeah I mean you just explore you get
lost you have fun it depends on it like
certain enemies drop different items to
so you find yourself like refreshing the
screen to go back to try to get that one
sword is there any
point in the game where you are a little
bit at odds with the randomness of it
and that can harm your run um this room
really doesn't have much luck if it
there is walk in it it's very subtle
things that don't make much of a
difference so I pasquina and means that
jumped around earlier like they can get
my way
and mess things up but other than that
yeah not not really
oh okay I'm sorry there's one big point
there's a skip for ID you have to jump
off in books and that makes a big
difference now giving you categories do
get pretty crazy with all Rafi and look
yeah like there's categories you can
beat the game with only one row
like the wolf rogue and you need a drop
to make that work so that that's a lot
of luck
yeah so the way I'm showing enemies is
also a time saver believe it or not this
game has a weird experience system where
it scales you up for more experience to
lower level you are compared to other
enemies so it ends up working out so if
you kill a certain sequence of enemies
you can actually save two or three level
up animations over the course of the run
compared to doing a different slightly
different route so cool that stays like
seven seconds or so it's all about the
seconds especially on a record good
thing oh well would you forget to zero
the axe armature okay so I could have I
forgot to do it you actually never do it
in a run slower but you can turn into
the axe armor there and then so oh right
there like as he told out chick repeater
it's alright I'll try and do it he knows
a lot of fun stuff yeah so you have to
play through this on the Saturn has
anyone ever tried speedrunning that
version oh yeah oh yeah well I'm laggy
so there's actually a character on that
that's exclusive Maria yeah and people
will actually do speaker on her a little
bit but other than that yeah it's mostly
just like you can show how glitching
slow and broken that version is EP play
yeah that one's really strange like like
every time there's an explosion the game
just comes to a halt pretty much as it
processes out the explosion then Flags
out horribly it takes every time you
choose to pause the game for any reason
you're wasting 10 seconds and a load and
between going in and out and what else
is brought that version like
transparencies are weird and that
doesn't doesn't look at you guys
obviously there's a weird thing like if
you if every screen transition go
through that game it puts you under the
four frog one frames just because it
can't process how you are supposed to go
normally I guess yeah other than that's
so normal nothing wrong with this game
and it's a stable game very hard to
glitch out very few bugs actually I mean
in a casual sense that's pretty much
true right I don't remember running in
anything like huge when I was playing it
the first time and then here's people to
talk about it and glitch finder and like
yeah I press few buttons I was in a wall
and I died instantly but it was pretty
cool yeah it's it's pretty similar to
like watching a zelda ocarina of time in
that way I don't think anyone playing
that their first time is really going to
run into anything suspicious unless
they're already like in a ghost hunting
or speedrun mindset and then everyone
else just like can find a million things
to do with the game
so that clock closes and opens every
minute so get in there and under nine
minutes is required for it to be open
and not really lose time
oops being good here is also required to
not waste time but so the thing that let
me get up here was that the anytime you
transform to something when you're in
the air if you go back out you can
actually dive kick straight down
normally you need double jump to get up
here but you can just like dive kick off
the candle out of a wolf and said that's
far I stopped the car guy because of the
experience route I was talking about
that stage seven seconds over the force
the run I kind of threw out a shield
when I landed there because that cancels
the landing animation and let's hey
shield - again faster your [ __ ] your
thing up saving off just yeah you know I
have a second two three frames sometimes
I'm trying to save each time I do stuff
like that so in one of the ridiculously
optimized games that actually keep
people keep hunting skips into small
breaks for it except its seconds at a
time instead of you know we skipped four
minutes or we skipped in time yeah I
mean that's always still being found for
this game
I think they were on the runs dropped
another fifteen or sixteen seconds in
the last three months yourself which is
I'm still quite a bit for per game like
this okay we'll try it once without
potion but I get that puck it won't work
and it worked okay so yeah there's
there's definitely walk with that book
going in the right position because
actually I kick off it yeah this is your
run um so I got the fairy cards I can do
another really complex for cheer so I
want to do a thing that exploded after I
go in or I'll just miss cuz I'm that a
menu your butt so her voice let me pause
during the cutscene there which normal
you shouldn't be able to do and so I
just sold the garnet with 0 garnets
being read in the menu and then like one
was on the screen so I just subtracted
one from zero and now I have 250 pots
because it just under poses so I feel
like I've seen a similar glitch in
blood-borne yeah pretty much the same as
that yeah definitely a connection there
and now you have a limited cache and you
can buy all the fun stuff nice shady now
that's similar to the duplication trick
and Final Fantasy Tactics uh you know
I'm actually not that familiar Final
Fantasy Tactics your comment on that I'm
sure that's okay but there's a very yet
as a very similar coming yeah probably
it's in a lot of games honestly a law
games to make use of over four or
underflow yeah the thing is the Maps
basically as quickly as you can food
especially older games actually capped
out 255 because of the system from the
right
what's great with this dashing is you
can do it with anything including you
know the food card which is involved
like food spluttering all over the place
you have to do for certain categories to
pick up a mushroom I believe I mean that
would be in this category it's
incredibly wok this anyway oh I'll give
a couple tries this trick it's you have
to start on the perfect pixel and then
do a frame perfect jump in a frame
perfect transform and it only stays like
ten seconds yeah it's not something
normally go through if I was doing a no
reset run but why not
live a little yeah okay one more try
interlibrary Carson and well worth the
extra nine hours I just wasted there got
a Christmas yep
it was a race though I probably will be
that nut again oh yeah I know I did a
race to just blast awesome games done
quick and I definitely didn't go for
that cuz it would have been too is she
attempt although I didn't erase before
that
this elevator has like its own batch of
fun glitches oh yeah
this time we it's completely used
normally though which is unfortunate hmm
think I was safe I could show it on so
the bat is like took such a long time to
get but it's by far the fastest for
moving because of your smooth called the
wind smash you have to hold jump and
then do a 3/4 circle starting look up
and you have to like release jump after
that and then just chain that in a 20 or
so frame window over and over again to
keep it going and wait some P times they
can't actually just do it instantly but
pretty close to enter if you touch
anything if you hit anything at ends
though yeah or if I just missed the
input because normally you're only
supposed to eat one disease like the
input required for this game ends up
being like fighting games extraordinaire
because you're just you're doing so many
quarter circles and having good control
yourself while flying through the air
like it's actually amazing the other
character Ricker in this version it's
like Dragon Punch is almost non-stop I
believe and they never really tell you
what those words are fairly looker yeah
you buy like a spell or something and
you could give you instructions yeah
oops oh I didn't set up correctly what's
the deal I remember there being a thing
where when you're going through is
Richter in the intro if you don't get
the items up there something special
happens when you come back as Alucard is
that correct no there's no difference if
those up there I thought like you got
different items depending whether you
grabbed no it's all the stuff I was
talking about in the intro actually with
just how fast you beat them and what
because things you end with gotcha okay
so I we have a frame of the bat
transformation we don't have a tick box
at all so I've used that by going over
the screen transition on that frame
and then it just kind of let me skip the
trigger for the go through battle so
instead of getting the gold and silver
ring and which in a speedrun setting
would still take about 10 minutes or so
I just ended up skipping all that yeah
I'd say that skip does save around like
10 minutes or so
savings missing a lot like that not a
huge fear I think well my favorite part
is run is I love the soundtrack of this
game and you get to hear like enough of
it did you get enough to actually enjoy
the game but it's gone as soon as you
enjoy it okay I get nothing installed
you to really enjoy it but not looking
up on YouTube after there's a lot like
subtle physics things going on at the
bat too but or just bad jumping that - I
love you'll see me doing this a lot and
I already have done a lot I'm using like
the mist transformation though I stopped
my momentum and reset it so I can change
direction faster another thing is like
if you're if you run on ceilings with
the bat and then hold up with the right
timing coming out of a wing smash you
actually just shoot vertically much
faster so you do all stuff like that
just to sake frames here and there like
there's a lot going on at the movement
in this game and it's actually way more
interesting to me as a speedrunner than
like even the coaches the coaches are
always fun like for people haven't like
seen a speedrun before but for people
like really know the game already like
all physics stuff is fun
there are two beams like these you see
intricacies and games like this when you
start getting to the deep speedruns it's
just it's super intriguing but you have
to already be at the point to be able to
appreciate it
versus still learning glitches for
learning this guess you're like pinching
frames at this stage and I don't even
know do you know at each stage in the
game how far you really should be for it
to be a good run do you want to know
does it harm you to actually be aware
yeah I mean I have a pretty good idea
like I know I'm going to finishing
slightly under 19 minutes right now I
think but yeah like most the time I'm
going for like a record run or something
then right now I would not be looking at
the timer like after I used to get to
the library read books skip is like at
that point out even care at the time I
just know whether I've messed up too
much after easy okay because like
mentally you've already known if you
could have done something faster it's
not like the time actually stops that
there are some people that do watch
their clock and I've seen people lose
runs there's a big racing community too
and I've seen people like they'll see
someone else finish choke because they
realize it and get first and then end up
losing a race more places yeah because
it broken their spirit that guy finish
Oh am I in trouble yes because I just
messed up when is it time um soon as
Dracula dies it'll probably be in like
20 or so so the second you finally hit
him and that's it like um yeah he will
the screen will fall yeah it'll be
obvious uh yeah so the way I got into
this section is actually pretty similar
to how I did the death skip it just
instead of a level up I eat the heart
refresh to do the butchering part so I
just no abuse the horizontal screen
scroll and then transformed into a
dissolves above the seal on the screen
done back wins you came trouble the soul
of my mother no more and Dracula's
probably up scary I think I could take
I've seen people die done meeting look
like this stuff he does still do like I
think 75 damage right now so it would
still to hit me and if I get hit once
you're probably combo to the second one
if he gains the world and loses his own
soul full of the dialogue in this game
26 so our ultimate goal for skin is to
actually reach 16 26 but no one's done
plan what what were Lisa's last words
she said one of those technically
possible to time with them I got a Super
Mario Brothers original they're trying
to shave up people been trying to shave
off one or two second associate and ends
up taking family no I've number one and
two times and Super Mario Brothers right
now is like one frame apart it's a
heartbreaking mode it's been that much
time just shaving off one more second
because it a game like Mario has
probably been done just so so much
because not only does it be loved but
it's old enough where you're getting
like a massive amount of community
fighting over it and trying to like find
these tiny little glitches and issues
with it it's so optimized that I feel
like a lot of people drop out before
they can get to like the top tier spots
because you have to really grind it out
and it's yeah it's fun it's phenomenal
and also just like it's such an
interesting to story to see someone go
through those stages me to see
heartbreaking I can't find anything else
you've already done it all there's
nothing less than I don't know what I'm
doing here even the people who like have
that record right now and are competing
for it even they're like well I mean I
know I can still say two frames and so I
still do attempts like they they know
what they can do even if anyone else
does plus their heart their who have
done I think Final Fantasy 7 do a full
run of that which is still you know a
good 9 or so hours like it's a long run
and then they'll finish the run and then
immediately boot up another game they
run to Final Fantasy 8 and then finish
that is just like Oh
dedication certainly well that was
awesome run thank you so much you know
well it's awesome I hope if you guys
like speed runs you can see more speed
runs because summer games done quick is
happening it is going to be happening
July 26 through August first they will
be playing all the time 24 hours a day
until it's done all sorts of amazing
games and all the benefits are going to
Doctors Without Borders so it's a great
it's a whole it's just an amazing event
it's lots of fun but it's all going
towards charity so it's just really
worth checking out so if you haven't yet
I suggest you do that